hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
don't worry nothing scary is gonna
happen in this intro absolutely nothing
that's just not my thing
[Music]
this is the visit you're being visited
by something or you are visiting
something or someone I'm not sure the
details but I don't think it matters
when it comes to horror games Oh an
explanation look I know you haven't seen
a lot of your grandma and that's my
fault but she's not doing well I think
you should go up there to see her it's
the right thing to do
she's become a bit of a recluse lately
so she'll enjoy the company I'll fly out
on the weekend you dare love you see you
soon oh and make sure you pack lots of
warm clothes
apparently it's record snowfall perfect
oh oh I'm already here I didn't even
need to approach the house at all
hello you have one new message message
received today at 5:30 4 a.m.
it's from mum I hope you made it demands
ok she well message me when you get this
ok well I won't message you a parent
whoa hello ok yeah that's normal
earthquakes associated with snowstorms
would make the light shake like that
Nan's prescription it's full help she's
taking them higher something tells me
she's not she possessed my many demons
hmm no easy sink is starting to smell
good that's all great all signs pointing
towards nan taking care of herself and
everything going well in this place let
her address to my mother your mother's
condition has worsened at times she's
reported being her sister however with
no record of any siblings it is in my
professional opinion that your mother's
developed the early stages of
dissociative identity disorder it
appears her dementia causes
vulnerabilities and a higher prevalence
of amnesiac episodes it is recommend she
moved to an assisted living facility to
ensure her safety
doctors oh my god I thought that was
like the silhouette of a nun like the
nun from that nun horror movie you know
the one what a picture of the one no no
not from the matrix know from the nun
slow then again I guess I shouldn't be
sprinting through Grandma's house it
might be unappreciated this is an
ominous looking door oh grandma I should
knock first yeah yeah yeah okay grandma
grandma either grandma has fallen and
she is very sick or she's a demon
I meant to knock I was thinking that was
the knocking button she isn't answering
I hope she's okay yeah that must be mom
talking okay
oh the light stopped all crooked like
that's normal
hey mom mom I don't know why it's
stuttering oh my phone's not there why
my phone is not a word what suppose
oh oh that's fun
but if nan remembers this remembers why
- whoa whoa nano have you taken your
pills Nana Nana great thanks man
what else you got for me Nana his Nana
turned into a giant spider monster
that's crawling around the ceiling and
I'm gonna see her skittering around the
corner at any moment coming to kill me
this isn't Nan's room it's just in Dan's
room that's impossible
it can't be Nan's room
I know Nan's room oh why oh well that's
fun oh good oh good
Nana man she's up but she's an answering
I need to pry the door open yeah sure oh
I'm looking in now oh I'm looking in now
I don't remember those candles being lit
before but that's probably fine
well that's an interesting sound that
you would do at that moment alright nan
I'm coming to get you I'm coming to help
y'all I'm coming to give you old well hi
okay Grampy Grampy bampi ain't doing so
good neither I need to find something to
pry the door open
what's beeping I don't see anything
beeping Oh at the coffee machine oh nice
Oh perfect
I would rather not if you were planning
to do anything to me I'd rather you
didn't do it you know just a preference
just perfect
this is a man's room
this isn't man's room either man Oh Oh
interesting
fascinating Nana Nana Nana Nana Nana who
are you in the corner of the room Nana
oh why why why okay take this weird key
I don't know why it keeps sticking every
time I try to do something oh
[Music]
you know neither eat naina you you're
nothing but skin and bones you know Anna
Anna I knew it my master spider monster
naina I knew it I knew it I knew it
spider monster Anna I called it I knew
it I don't what what do i I don't know
what I hate that I don't know what I
need to do do I need to get out the
front doors this is the key to the front
doors that I want anything no I don't
understand what I need it out listen
Anna listen Anna listen
ya know you need to take your pals take
your pills
no let me out let me out let me out let
me out oh you're outside it's freezing
cold in an acquittal addressed and
running barefoot through the snow you
see your mother's car enters the
driveway screaming you run to her and
explain what you've seen with a look of
disbelief she insist that you calm down
come inside you resist grabbing your arm
she drags you towards the house a dread
overwhelms your body as you enter your
house to grandmother's standing in the
front of the fireplace she turns to your
mother with a smile let's begin great
maybe I should have put on some clothes
that was interesting is that the end is
there more than one ending is that is is
that that I don't know pretty good I
like that I mean I hated it but you know
painted it in a way that's like yeah it
was pretty cool there's a game called
don't open your eyes don't know why I
would choose one way hey that's pretty
cool
you're not supposed to do that oh boy
what a beautiful day my eyelids have
begun feel heavy I better go to sleep
let's see oh I thought it was morning I
live beside the book I've been reading
and look out my window the process of
falling asleep is always a struggle
against noise barking dogs
police sirens or even my own intrusive
thoughts but not even the turning years
of my brain up loosing my sound the
night is just oddly quiet
what freak sleeps with their door open
what nightmare human is so confident
that they are the most terrifying thing
in the middle of the night that they're
willing to sleep with your door open
can't believe it here I go then it's me
haha secret answer is me too quiet I
feel Restless my sight veers told the
hallway outside of my door
the distance between my room in the
opposite wall is only ten steps long I
know since I've made a habit of counting
them whenever I go out one two three
absent mindedly but always I don't know
why maybe I just like being aware of my
surroundings to the smallest details but
a night is different the hallway looks
like it stretches into nothingness like
the throat of a gargantuan beasts yeah
that's why you close it logical thinking
Christ said it's just my imagination
there can't be anything wrong or
different about it it's just a hallway
yeah but it's about what's in the
hallway but I don't want to look at it
so I take a deep breath and close my
eyes or closed or close it lock it put
it in a stool in my room oh there's a
bed in my room oh there's a wardrobe ah
I see where you got going on here in my
room there's pictures framed on the wall
very nice my room is part of myself it's
a world I know like the back of my hand
where someone to blindfold me and asked
me to find my way around I do so without
the slightest difficulty as long as
nothing changes having my eyes closed
makes no difference
in this room I can always find what I
want to find because in this room I know
how everything looks I need to wake up
early tomorrow
I should really try to sleep Snoozeville
here I come this is why this is why
I hate it what's that sound better not
open my eyes are those footsteps that's
six steps it's ten steps seven no that's
impossible
11 in closer they're gone
no that's not the conclusion to make
there the conclusion is that they
stopped and they are right there right
there's no way someone could be there oh
God
was that me Oh interesting
that's fascinating that's a thing oh I
hate you I'm the voice actor here you go
to hell okay do I open my eyes hmm
no he said oh it has saved I was safe I
don't know baby sure I open my eyes oh
good there's nothing there
oh all right yeah okay all right I'll
play a lot no I don't open my eyes not
gonna open my eyes I swear to god I'm
not gonna do it
you cannot me here you can't make me
listen sir I know I bet you're so
beautiful I would just fall in love I do
my best to ignore the voice because you
are I hear in my room what they're in my
room yes it is it is I can feel someone
breathing over my ear it's cold I don't
want any of your secrets and if your
secrets are in your pants I definitely
don't want any part of it that's
wonderful and I won't either hideous I
can tell by the smell funnily enough I
don't see color so I'm the wrong person
to ask
me neither let's keep it that way I'll
think about it there's a mirrors for
that those exist me too
I don't like to look at things grade you
could hide now - great this is a
fantastic conversation I love where this
is going
so why don't you forget yourself and
just disappear from existence great even
better
ah do you though
tiny ears I've been told my ears are
extremely dirty and how dare you
stronger than you buddy boo all my ears
I'm very threatened
I feel something caressed my ears all
right listen buddy if you're gonna
threaten to tear something off my ears
are the least of my concerns
even a sleeping person would scream
they'd wake up screaming oh I knew it
me too who's I don't know that person
that's that's weird
hey what's up bulbous
I probably my car keys I've lost those I
said it might mean my wallet what do you
want or their eyes look like I don't
know they look broke did your eyes are
broke yeah it's weird like cracked and
dead the gears are all falling outs very
strange oh no I don't like that babies I
don't like your eyes I'm always training
my sight
I picked the worst answer I'm sorry sir
precious ting by ear it's what drives me
to look inside places such as this
fascinating it stops training sorry you
shouldn't try it should feel natural
that's so cool okay right okay you know
what makes me sad my lack of sleep so
maybe you could just help me be happy
and go away so I can get down to sleep
in town Junction ah there's your problem
I found while you're in your eyes are
crackit I take it out alright this seems
counterproductive I take everything out
everything you mean your brains you do
seem pretty stupid to give back what's
mine I didn't I've already lost I
haven't lost anything not me because I'm
asleep baby
it's
and are you really crying oh so
conveniently you cry these invisible
tears and then you don't feel sorrow I
don't think you were really sad
have you ever strained yourselves so
hard to see what you want to see Hey
what I dropped my glasses I guess end up
finding myself I just said I dropped my
glasses that was the whole point
yeah have i oh yeah man they're your
eyes look at them how could they not be
yeah I only give good answers there's
only one way to know the truth uh-huh ah
do I open my eyes I book oh yeah let's
do it
I open my eyes oh that's sad
so is that gonna be like every time god
this guy's this guy's our freak this
guy's a freak you've described yourself
so perfectly your eyes no how could you
know they're called eyelids you freak
around like yeah pearls is pretty good
no I minored chocolate like mud no thank
you
a breath of gold air caresses my
eyelashes not my eyelashes fine we still
have time no he's funnily enough I got a
test tomorrow still about to get a lot
louder
uh-huh great this is a cool conversation
I miss you actually saying thanks to me
that's less creepy than you're breathing
in my eyelashes not me no I've got door
blindness how dare you oh yeah that's
what I was saying you're bad I would
never have guessed
I can't I'm just stupid I find them
cheeky
ah so your stupid [ __ ] to push very
stupid
should I try to take it off its hinges
should I should blow away at it I'll
pick it will fall apart and what happens
what happens you go through it do I
you were talking about manners not me do
I keep it out
I don't know there you go there's your
answer
this is a fascinating conversation so
many so many wow this is really
interesting
great could I get some sleep yep closed
doors is the idea they exist to keep me
out that fills me with the need oh oh
it's a metaphor things I get it it's
metaphorical great it's a cellar dust
with dirt ah grey like my lungs
just sometimes you bother me don't talk
about swelling urges ever again okay oh
gosh oh that's me baby that was the
reason yeah do you know the first thing
about consent man oh boy oh what'd you
reach it for there ah yes a firm
handshake oh you don't know what warm is
don't use that terminology not always
hey why me so slimy alright I guess so
it's just this is a nod so I'll just do
this would ya all right cool they look
tired deceitful they look incomplete
deceitful you've got mischievious hands
oh yeah your entire my life is not
deceitful
[Music]
with me sometimes yeah I don't know
about that unlikely sustenance uh-huh
but I'm also do afraid to find out the
truth so I let them stay with me okay
part of me okay crow okay I've grown so
much
oh good you're tall
these fingers won't stop fingers
describing it coil it around everything
they feel it's I can only hope
uh-huh we said it my body grew too much
because I wouldn't get to enter rooms
like yours anymore oh hey hey to help
yourself crow but mercilessly taking
away from someone else have you huh are
these my hands hands thank you I only
give them apparently we're dogging
there's only one way to know the truth
open your eyes interesting interesting
idea let's try it how many time gonna be
fooled every time so obviously how this
is gonna go there's but there's gonna be
that one no even though my hands could
be the same as yours Oh
think about it maybe you and I are
similar no I can feel it oh no mmm
you've got some thumpy skin oh I hear
something
[Music]
my skin is oh god [ __ ] out since what
happened
it's aside of my entry most emotions
flowing down this casting stuff flowing
your emotions all over me the world
watching to be satisfied as long as
someone tells me how I look it's not
like I don't want to satisfy you
oh and let me guess everything has to be
hard with you myself yeah why don't you
why don't you
might not be the answer I wish for uh
since I don't want to be Josh oh you're
really fragile ego to be perceived as
something I'm not right of course
scares me uh well might be happening now
that's why when someone is on the verge
of looking at me shy away yeah of course
hide into the dark you might be
different don't you it might be possible
to stand still if only for a sec we have
such a deep connection you and me you
can help me I will help you both don't
fulfill me just
and pulsating feel feel feel I cannot
describe you know you're wonderful at it
that's what taught me to speak like a
purse wow I'm so happy for the Mac okay
I can tell because I'm sure you remember
it perfectly because it makes me think
of I I want to be seen I don't care much
for my appearance I don't think that's
how this works watch someone recognize
myself
dude start a YouTube channel you'll get
seen so bus you'll get record that it'll
be great
you'll be so popular with those hands
you're gonna maybe start like a channel
on pornhub or something but you know you
you've got a lot of potential it's only
because I can uh as everyone gets to be
recognized you will owe your pulsating
skin I'm not gonna feel anything on to
you just look at you I knew it I
suspected from the very beginning this
was gonna confer verse
finally those types of yours you never
call my lips tight ever ever again
Ron Ron not Ronald literally Ron Ron Oh
Ron yeah Ron tell me Ron don't be so
ridiculous
hey fella finally disappear on its a
cheerful smile oh yeah Ron you don't
think of Ron without thinking about a
smile and it only makes sense for the
end of this journey to bring me joy Ron
baby that's been so-so Oh remember
Ronnie boy to say it had a beginning Oh
who's to say it has an end drama
standpoint is that faint memory Ron the
earliest one I can uh-huh
okay I doubt it and for some reason it
was daytime doubt it so I must have
believed Oh once or twice thrice or
price this expression is this uh yes
it's not a good answer you're welcome I
know yeah features as you should the
rest of you is horrifying yes you're
welcome
please disconnect oh do I
there's other ways you can take a
picture of yourself you can text it to
me I will text you my opinion with a
restraining order attached to it double
fun please great oh man you know I would
love to I would love to I would love to
imma give it a try let's study for me
four times [ __ ] when will I learn my
lesson old man no no
yeah well no haha I don't understand I
don't know it's fine you gonna cry you
help me by answering my question some
good no one has done that for me before
oh so I have no right to ask for
anything else
uh-huh
no oh wait I don't like it I would lie
to me ever since I stepped into this
room
oh you ever fears to engage with me yes
not even once
oh not even once not even once not even
once not even once not even once not
even once not even once did you look at
my face uh-huh
you stayed there acting as if you're
asleep mm-hmm feigning ignorance and not
moving an inch at times making me
believe that her conversation was just
in my head
hey you haven't opened your mouth mm-hmm
but you didn't need to
I can hear far far beyond what most
others can uh-huh I can't see further
than what others would consider the dark
empty bottom uh-huh that's why I know
uh-huh uh-huh that way your eyes are
cracked you are like me mm-hmm
we are the same look at my hands we're
exactly the same you to look for what's
not there you to reach after what might
hurt you mm-hmm are a liar mark a liar
thank you very much time that shows one
thing and feels another uh-uh but you
made a mistake I made many I know you're
lying
Oh because every answer you've given me
so far has been our own good answers I
am NOT what you said I am Oh these eyes
these ads this expression uh-huh oh well
goodbye
see you're out that's mine okay all I
see but I do not like a Rorschach test
not anymore open your eyes
don't want to be judged I didn't want to
be perceived for something or not and
that's all you did well you know so now
you will open your eyes and see me for
what I truly am okay you said so no I
don't I don't know this film you know
how everything looks
you got me there those words that
brought me uh-huh
my ego and sobbed against you you have
to do right by that what you claimed
okay
you make a sound argument your eyes yo
didn't hear that one well look so sure
your chance I'm drying it I was gonna
open your eyes I said yes well I said
yes hmm something coils around my head
depression around my skull is unbearable
ah here's something shatter your eyes
are as beautiful as I imagined tell me
my new friend great what see I want to
answer but they've grabbed out of my
head and won't let me talk but I see
what I see is
[Applause]
my eyes good you can't see any more
right
you can't talk anymore right you can't
think anymore right then this is very
well thank you for trying friend even
though you are a liar
I leave this piece of myself here with
you
great I must know I must look for the
right person someone who can tell me how
I look I'm beginning to think that
there's someone who can't explain to me
why everyone looks like that when they
do good talk pal great talk buddy
fantastic conversation there god that
was trippy that was cool that was a
different horror experience than I've
had in the past but really not that bad
there's something in my hand it's what
they left behind
what is it feels important how am I
still alive I thought he smashed my head
hoping but I can no longer open my eyes
interesting well but I tried to open my
eyes
do I have my eyes no oh wait no that's
not this one you had your chance
you know it's all the same alright so I
don't know if there's a different
combination for that game to actually
get you to some different ending but
that's fascinating because that is a
different way it's less like jump scary
horror but more
just like this surrealist experiential
discomfort which is cool too because
it's it's still horror but it's in a
completely different vein I like that if
you guys want to try that for yourself a
puddling in the description
maybe there's another ending to get
alright so this one might be short it
markets itself as a extremely short
horror game I just don't know how short
dear Alex mom and I went to dinner with
rustles the fuse and the garage is
broken so the motion sensor might make
the garage door get stuck make sure it's
closed before you go inside we left you
some money for pizza see you soon and be
safe love dad okay
press space fund what to push
what
it's a horror game about a garage
ooh okay I get it now
oh I get it oh that's not good
oh wait hang on a second oh wait oh oh
hi hey buddy yes right oh you writing
something over there
what are you doing who that no no no the
opposite the opposite the opposite the
opposite the opposite of that all right
hi yeah he doing buddy hey all right
okay very short but uh not bad not bad
not bad not bad
all right so the reason I played this is
because this developer made another game
that's also very short so I figured
we'll do a twofer here and we'll call it
one not bad kind of creepy I like it
well spooky you're a little spook and
then you're out and that's it sometimes
that's all you need
Oh
this one's called like run to nowhere or
something like that okay all right let's
run to nowhere it's like when I go out
for my night runs Chris a and d de oh
yeah press quicker to run quicker okay
here we go all right let's fly it on
these city streets going for a nice jog
we're gonna make a stoic band you I
interesting that's fascinating that that
would be a mechanic crickets chirping
the Turkish yeah okay
all right uh-huh this is inconvenient at
best I don't really hear any crickets
but leaves rustle gently in the wind
thank you without that description I
would never know that trees rustling
gently in the winds my fingers are tired
I can hear them Oh pray tell
oops do you hear Oh someone knocked over
this bench interesting
I will saw your open your jaw so that
our Lord may enter your heart and soul
[Music]
wait I've got an idea
so if I did this right I've made a macro
on my mouse here
that's alternates a and D so I can run
real fast this time we're going
somewhere and not know where I'm about
to break this game I'm gonna have to
break this game in half
here we go there we go we are fly you
never gonna catch me I'm too fast for
you I'm kickin ass takin names
I could hear who I can't hear anything
over the sound of my legs Lord look your
Lord can't even see me let alone catch
me I'm gonna need baby well hi that's
awfully and could be it's the problem
hmm
well Oh interesting can you give me a
hand here I feel oh alright so there's
no way alright fine screw you I beat
your alright so that is three scary
games thank you everybody so much for
watching if you enjoyed these let me
know down the comments below and if you
got other scary games you want to see
let me know down there as well check out
more scary games that I played in the
description or in the playlists or in
the suggested videos down there thanks
again and as always I will see you
Hawaii
[Music]